المواجهه المسلحه القت بظلال سلبيه على
قطاعات حيويه ومهمه في البلاد هنا في شرق
السودان تبرز معاناه سائق الشاحنات
المتوقفين عن العمل كواحده من تداعيات
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان
والله المشكله انه العربات دي شاحنه
والطبعا الوضع ما منه ما قادرين نتحركوا
يعني عندنا عربات امس طلعت
اول نقطه عبور ونرجعها على اساس البلد ما
في عمل
دي اكبر مشكله
رمضان لغايه الان ما تتحرك هو عربات شحن
وقاعده بس
زي ما شايفين
والله شاحنين سكر شاحن دقيق
الخرطوم وواحدين ماشي الابيض
هذا الوضع تدفع غرف النقل بولايه البحر
الاحمر بمطالبها وتتحدث عن خسائر باهظه
كمرحين اصحاب شاحنات
او زياده يعني هذا من جانب اما بقيه
الملفات الخدميه والتنمويه فان السلطات في
ولايه البحر الاحمر تؤكد العمل على
استقرار الاوضاع والتعاطي بايجابيه مع
قضيه اجلاء رعايه دول الاجنبيه الوضع
الامني بصفه عام ممتاز جدا وهادي على
مستوى العشر محليات
الامن في هذه الولايه يمكن الحياه تصير
بصوره طبيعيه كما شاهدتموها
ايضا الاسواق النشاط التجاري بصوره ممتازه
بصوره طبيعيه ما شاء الله ما عندنا مشاكل
اياميه يمكن بالاخوه
العالقين حتى ما غادروا السودان نحن عن
طريق التنسيق مع منظمات المجتمع المدني
والاخوه الخيرين في مدينه بورسودان الان
تم اعداد ما يقارب سبعه مناطق قوى منتشره
بورسان تقدم فيها كل الخدمات من مياه شرب
ووجبات لم تقدم من هؤل الاخوه
والبرنامج بصوره ممتازه جدا نزار البغداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من مدينه بورسودان
شرقي السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات